to visit ladylike to even approach there
is a feminine way right tell us the
feminine way because I would love to
know women communicate differently men
communicate overtly whilst women
communicate covertly part of what women
do they they
signals you know you know back in the
day they used to be like they used to
drop their
handkerchiefs also also I'm just gonna
give you a quick plug
um we're starting wife uh a channel
called wife school where we bring in
some wives to teach modern women and
304s to be wives
okay I always say three or fours or
three or fours uh-huh
okay all right anyway so so if you if
you feel like you've been in the streets
too long I can't believe this
I'm a modern woman I don't know what to
do and you're like all these red pill
channels they never come up with
Solutions but here we're solution minded
we're gonna bring it we're gonna bring
in wives to teach you how to cook wives
to teach you how to push it what follow
my channel I'll give you Solutions
that's what I do
you're gonna teach women how to approach
approach men right very true okay
I would love a little lesson now okay so
situation this is not a situation you're
a ball you're with your girlfriends you
see God you like first off you've been
with your girlfriends right 99 of men
are not approaching you because to him
you just like a pack of wolves okay it's
not happening so the first thing you
have to do is you have to separate
yourself from the group
okay right and there's a point that you
separate yourself from the group now
while you're in the group right you see
the guy you like it's very important you
make eye contact now here's the thing
when you're out and about everyone makes
eye contact right you might look guys
once or twice right but you need to
maintain that eye contact right so you
see him he sees you right the next thing
you do right if you do that and he
acknowledges you that's cool next time
you do it you give a smile
because all it is about right because
thing is if you're not attractive women
if you're an attractive woman 80 of guys
want to approach you in that club but
the truth is 79 feel they don't have the
permission to so by you doing this is
giving him the permission to approach
you once you've done and you've sent
these signals you have to separate
yourself from the group okay so maybe
like oh to be like girls go to toilet
all the time so maybe not toilet but
maybe you're like okay I'm gonna go get
a drink at this side of the bar where
I'm by myself and you give him the
opportunity now here's the thing
if it's a man who is with his world with
all he's got a level of emotional
intelligence right and he finds you
attractive and he's there's a level of
confidence which I assume is the kind of
man you want he's going to take that
chance
and if he doesn't let's say he doesn't
right I mean like I didn't take a chance
but if you come back
if you see him up at the bar right and
I've said this to my clients and this is
worked several times
all you say is hey can you help me try
and get you I've been trying to get a
drink for ages and they've not been seen
to me and if what if there's like no one
in the bar you're a [ __ ] ball if there's
no one at the bar well then you know
he's that's definitely the signal though
because all you're doing is you're just
opening a door and nine times out of ten
right nine times out of ten a guy's
gonna go because a guy wants to feel
like the man to go don't worry man let
me get us a drink right and then you
start a conversation and that is that is
literally half the battle of meeting
that I'm coming to you with your friends
my husband would have approached me with
the friends and taken me away that's
cool but most but like no no you're a
one percent man if you can do that
because most of the code approaches is
the
difference they don't practice the skill
of the cold approach anymore of course I
grew up doing that stuff so I yeah
you grew up yeah 100.
I'll be honest I used to do that Blood
Sweat and rejection is what I used to
call it back after them days you just
have to grind we used to do a numbers
game me and my boy would go to a certain
locations Let's see we get 10 numbers
wow Freedom at reply you might be able
to top one
used to the same thing but the reason I
didn't do that now and I don't advocate
for men to do that now because ain't no
one looking for a sexual harassment
charge no no no no no but the thing is
and the reason I say it was important
whilst you're younger is because you
learn how to communicate with people
effectively at that age yeah so at the
time and that's when you learned to pick
up social cues because women will signal
yeah where most men fails they're not
attune to those signals and I can see
with the separation of the friends just
smile most guys will still see all those
signals and stuffing [ __ ] that like yeah
I'd only get turned down that's true but
for me that's that's a heightened
approach if you give me all those
signals it's long yeah but that's how
much fun use game over I hear that but
like most but like I said that's a one
percent man thing most guys aren't going
to do that yeah that's true and I've
noticed that as well like when I was
younger a lot of guys would like come up
well I'm not like bigger myself out but
you know like guys generally like they
had so much more confidence whereas
nowadays I just feel like they never
approach you that's because
do you think that you can go to a go
yeah I've all like not always but yeah
there's been a lot of times where I have
approached a guy to be fair I have been
drunk
right
um it is harder like when you're sober I
don't know like I don't have as much
confidence but yeah like I like that
what do you say
oh
okay this is a bit strong and bear in
mind I was drunk right but in one
scenario I said are you gonna get me a
drink
um okay that's all right but I say in
like a feminine way I smart you I mean
like there's like body language to this
as well
honestly it's because it might come up
with that one yeah for sure because for
me I only really like to buy a girl
drink only when we're having great
interactions because a lot of guys where
they go wrong is that that's their
that's their
approaching and to me that's Sleazy and
it shows you've got no decorum now girls
will finish you for that though exactly
a drink mate do you know how come on you
guys have had it like how many girls go
out they're like they don't even spend a
penny but they get wasted oh yeah they
don't come out of their persons
one guy's approached me said I want to
chat to your financial brother go do
your thing she'd come back to me with
free drinks wow I'll be there I'll be
honest maybe I shouldn't admit this I'll
be honest I've been out with a girl that
I was dating right and she was done and
she gets hit on all the time by guys I
know and like she'll be like let me go
get some drinks I should just go get a
guy to buy if I play a drink she's like
oh can you buy a drink for me or my
friend not knowing it's for me wow I'll
be like listen if you're a team you use
what each other has got but hey it's
true Did you know that they're
predicting that 50 of women
um in childbearing years so basically
between the ages of like 25 and 45 will
be single and childless so much so that
there's big companies investing in
things like wine cat food wow I've
invested in egg freezing because that's
going to become more yeah
that's really good idea what does that
say about the state of modern women
today
um
um
it's kind of sad really it's sad but
never mind
Cambridge is actually I think I'll
listen to LBC and Cambridge designed to
do courses on fertility for women
because they believe that girls aren't
taught young enough about their bodies
so they talk as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and I'm
demonetized on
term if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible